Now I'm going to talk about Tag Manager.
I'll be covering two
main uses of Tag Manager.
First, I'll talk about how to use it
to send dynamic configuration data to
your app.
For example, if your app's a game,
you could offer different challenges for
different levels, depending on
the attack strength the player has left.
If you ran a shopping app,
you could use Tag Manager to
change the daily discount offer.
The second use of Tag Manager relates
to organizing and managing tags.
A tag is a fragment of code that
performs some kind of tracking function.
In the previous lesson,
you added tags to your app to send
tracking data to Google Analytics.
Instead of sending data
directly to Google Analytics,
you could send it to Tag Manager, which
can then send it on to Google Analytics.
It's easy to change the way the data
is reported to Google Analytics using
the Tag Manager dashboard,
without having to change your code.
And Tag Manager helps you visualize and
organize your tags.
You'll learn how to create tags to
forward hit data from your app to
Google Analytics in the next lesson.
In this lesson,
you'll learn how to use Tag Manager to
dynamically update values in your app.